[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
joe biden's announcement on his vice
presidential running mate is reported to
be
imminent our sources say the former vice
president has talked with
all of the people on his list ed o'keefe
is covering campaign 2020 so ed
what else are we hearing about the
potential vice presidential pick
good morning vlad our understandings
that joe biden has now spoken with his
top finalists for the job either in
person
or remotely last week for example he met
with the governor of michigan gretchen
whitmer but other meetings with other
contenders occurred virtually
those contenders of course include
california senator kamala harris
california congresswoman karen bass
former national security adviser susan
rice and senator elizabeth warren among
many others
they all remain on standby and a
decision is still expected
at some point this week the binding
campaign insists that the way we will
officially learn of his choice is
through a text message sent to the
former vice president's supporters
and once he names a running mate whoever
she is biden and her
are expected to headline a virtual
fundraiser with supporters in hopes of
raising big campaign cash
off of the announcement
intriguing and intriguing all right the
convention's less than a week away what
are you hearing about a potential
lineup that's right well remember this
convention is happening virtually so
it'll be a mix of taped and live video
messages from democrats and others all
across the country
among the biggest names set to speak are
former ohio
republican governor john kasich who's
set to be part of a
republicans for biden group he's on
monday along with bernie sanders and
michelle obama
on tuesday former president bill clinton
new york congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez and dr jill biden are on
tap
wednesday includes remarks from former
president barack obama and the vice
presidential nominee
whoever she is and thursday's big event
is biden's acceptance speech it's going
to amount vlad essentially
to the most political of zoom conference
calls ever held
sounds about right ed okey for us thank
you ed